Film Courage: So then an example of a flat
character versus a more 3-dimensional character,
like even in just a description of something.
Can you give me one sentence that is flat
versus one that tells you volumes in this
one sentence?
Karl Iglesias: Right.
So you see this a lot.
This is more about cliché writing so you’ve
got a character description where I read this
all the time “Oh, she’s beautiful or handsome!”
You know, it’s the same…
Film Courage: It tells me nothing.
Karl Iglesias: It tells you nothing, right!
It’s the same old thing you’ve seen a
hundred times.
So you’ve got to be a little more creative.
It’s all about creativity and originality.
I think originality comes from being curious.
The more curious you are about something,
the more you know about something, the more
you can avoid copying something, right?
I think the people who have cliché writing
because they don't know what’s been done
before, so to them it’s new so they go “Oh!”
because they think it’s good.
But people who know and have seen it a hundred
times, because they’re curious, will say
it’s cliché because they’ve seen it a
hundred times.
Film Courage: Versus a character description
of somebody that says “His eyes sparkled…”
I mean…oh…that is so cliché.
Karl Iglesias: Right.
It’s the whole cliché thing, right.
They just don’t bother to go deeper.
You know what I mean?
You’ve got to be original.
Originality is very important because if you
read the same thing over and over again, you’re
not going to respond to it.
That is actually the bane of a writer’s
existence, especially a screenwriter, to come
up with something new.
When you think about, I think in the second
edition of 101 Habits, Bill Marsilii one of
the screenwriters there, talks about doing
the 20’s.
So for him anything that he thinks about,
any event, any scene, character whatever,
he thinks of kind of listing 20 different
ways of doing it.
He talks about the meet-cute in romantic comedy,
he talks about how people meet in a cute way.
Well he’s going to do 20 different thoughts
about it.
“Okay it could be this, it could be this…”
He does 20 because the first two or three
or five of them will be clichés.
They will be things that you’re automatically
going to think about because they’re the
most famous ones that we’ve seen a hundred
times.
But going deeper (and he forces himself to
go deeper) that is where you get the creativity
and originality.
And eventually when you reach past the 10
to 12 or 15 all the way up to 20, you’ll
start getting really original ways because
you force yourself.
And so that is what the writer needs to do.
Force yourself to go deeper in order to create
some original writing.
Film Courage: Right…so getting out all…probably
number 1 through 5 is just total clichés?
Karl Iglesias: Right.
You can try it as a game.
It’s a tip that he uses as a habit of creativity
to do the 20 for just anything.
It could be 20 different ways to rob a bank.
20 different ways to say I love you.
20 different ways to break up with someone.
20 different ways to be mean to someone.
There are all these different things that
you’ve seen a 100 times and when you see
it over and over again you go “Hmm…”
because you’ve seen it a 100 times and it’s
only the movies that break out…stories that
break out are the ones that are truly original,
right?
Film Courage: So let’s take the movie GREEN
CARD with Gérard Depardieu and Andie MacDowell.
So that probably be further down the list,
I would think?
It’s a cute movie.
It’s original.
Karl Iglesias: Right.
It was an interesting movie.
That is the thing about what I love about
romantic comedies is that it’s such a set
story in terms of shape, in terms of structure.
In terms of Boy-Gets-Girl or vice versa Girl-Gets-Boy,
Girl-Loses-Boy-Gets-Boy-In-The-End.
It’s the same thing.
All romantic comedies are the same literally.
But the ones that I think we pay attention
to and that are successful are the ones who
have the unique angle to it.
[For instance] HOOK, same thing only different.
The only different are the ones like GREEN
CARD or ETERNAL SUNSHINE OF THE SPOTLESS MIND
or even THE BREAK UP which is a romantic comedy
where they break up as opposed to getting
together.
So whenever you come up with a unique angle
to that story that we all know, the better
for you.
That is where originality comes in.
And it gets harder and harder because the
more romantic comedies there is, the harder
it is to come up with something new, you know?
That’s the way it is.
Question for the viewers: Have you ever brainstormed
a list of 20 ideas?
Is this something you will now try?